[Music]
hey everybody welcome to planet coaster
college today I'll be talking about the
spinning coaster which in game is known
as spiral now there are many different
types of spinning coasters in the world
from which aside from the fact that they
are spin are very different and if you
want to make a realistic spinning
coaster these differences are something
that you want to keep in mind and that's
why I'll get into a slightly longer than
usual back story here the in-game
spinning coaster is a motor design since
they come in single cars with seats
spinning outward and these are also the
most common type of spinning coaster
like some famous examples are winches at
phantasialand or spin more Whizzer at
Alton Towers but even for this one
coaster there are many different types
and there are also many different
companies which make these closest so I
want to quickly start with saying what
makes this a motor spinning coaster and
then delve into what types of motor
spinning causes that are and what way
you should want to build it in planet
coaster and eventually hopefully maybe
one day we'll build one as well so
that's the plan basically the way that
we know that this is a motor spinning
coaster is because there are also
spinning coasters manufactured by other
companies there are girl our spinning
coasters but these hyper seats
face the center of rotation of the car
so you're looking at the other riders
instead of your surroundings the same
goes for spinning coasters manufactured
by intamin and there are also MEC
spinning coasters which look a lot like
the Indian spinning coaster but they
actually come in trains instead of just
one car so we definitely know it's not
those so by the looks a bit the in-game
spinning coaster is a motor design but
it doesn't actually make it that much
more simple yet because the spinning
coaster like this one is definitely not
to be confused with a wild mouse coaster
I've already seen many people build wild
most style coasters with the spinning
coaster but of this type it's actually
usually a complex coaster that spins
around but with a smooth flowing layout
with large drops and banked curves
whereas traditional wild Mouse's or what
nice I only have
very small hairpin turns and simple
drops so it's a bit more of a modern
take on the wild mouse I think that's
probably the easiest way to to get to
understand it so it is a bit different
and even though you can make a
traditional what most with it and I
definitely think that's still really
cool idea in this video I want to get
into the real new sort of marks tetanus
is and there are two basic types of
these motor spinning courses there's the
standard models and there are custom
models and all the standard models
they're actually three different models
the first one is the SC thousand which
is only about 11 meters store is
actually very very similar to the
traditional mouse coasters and has just
a few hairpin curves and some drops
there's the SC 2001 Oh which is very
common standard model with all kinds of
different curves MA then there's the SC
2200 model of which there's only one
which is spin ball Whizzer at Alton
Towers now these are all standard models
so if you want to recreate any of these
I'll put some links in the description
to where you can find the layouts
there's actually an entire brochure of
what's pinball wizard is like and for
the models as well model has some
brochures on the coasters which can be
really interesting to read through if
you really want to go for that pure
realism or if you just interested in it
but basically these things can all just
be very faithfully recreated by looking
at the real-life versions the most
interesting type is that last type of
spinning coaster which is the SC 3000
and this is the spinning coaster with
custom layouts which means that every SC
3000 spinning coaster is different but
they all have some some similarities
based on which you can make a realistic
spinning coaster and that is what I want
to try today and show you how these
things more or less work so as a quick
summary we've got all kinds of different
spinning coasters from different
manufacturers the one in game is a motor
spinning coaster which means that it's
not a traditional world mouse coaster
and instead it has some banked curves
and it's a very smooth twisty kind of
layout and there are different types of
these monitors bidding courses as well
there are some standard models and then
there are custom models and the custom
ones are the ones which are always
different and one of these focusing on
in this video so with all that out of
the way and without further ado let's
get into making one we can find the
cursor down here in the bottom of the
coaster section and the station is
actually relatively small for these
types of courses this is actually
already a somewhat large station and you
don't really have to worry about raising
up too much they are usually quite low
to the ground and from the station it is
actually quite usual for these courses
to go into the little straightaway as
well and before I'm going into the
littles I do want to get a small break
section in as well
and already get a catwalk so it does
connect to the station and then we're
going to go up with the lift Hill which
kind of as per usual can just be about
30 degrees and since we are dealing with
30 small cars here it can be a very
short sort of snappy transition into the
little here something like that should
more or less do now as for the heights
of these courses they are actually quite
low usually somewhere between the 15 and
25 meters is where you'd want to go
realistically now for the top of the
list so we want to make sure that always
we want to go down a little bit so that
we're actually getting coming off the
lift hill and we can't really store
there and what I also really want to
note about this is that you can actually
feel free to make this a super fast
little usually these things go up super
rapidly so might as well up the speed of
that a little bit and after we get off
the lift Hills
sometimes they kind of curve about they
don't usually get into a straight drop
straight down so in this case I'm going
to do something similar to that as well
what I do want to do though is turn on
the banking offset which is just going
to help us
make those curves a little bit more
smooth as we start to bank the car is
sort of going to state in the middle of
the Bank which especially for spinning
houses where you're going to be curving
quite a lot and having the car spin
around as well is something that will
help out in the long run making this
thing a bit more smooth now what I
actually want to try in here is just
start off with the first section where
we're not entirely going to dive into
the ground yet to be very honest I am
just winging it with this layout so I'm
really just basing it on what these
things are like generally and in this
case I think I'm going to steal a bit
from a coaster of which I don't actually
remember the name anymore because they
recently changed it something with Nara
anyway a small sort of pre real part
section where it just drops down a
little bit and gets into a sweeping
curve underneath the lift over here and
then we're going to do something else
with this yeah let's go up a little bit
and prepare for a block break section
now you might be surprised as to why
exactly I'm heading into a block break
section now reason for that is that
these causes to tend to have block
breaks throughout their entire layout
quite a few and there's there is an
important reason for that basically no
coaster is allowed to be on the same
block at any given time and since these
coasters run very small cars but a lot
of very small cars at the same time on
the layout you need a lot of book breaks
in order to be able to run multiple
trains on the track at a time so we're
definitely going to realistically need
all of these block breaks so let me just
get a quick look break section in here
and for all of these book breaks just
for realism purposes I like to attach a
catwalk to it as well there we go now
this looks terrible of course
so as for my smoothing I usually just
kind of grab the different parts at once
and after I'm done doing that grab an
entire section of track between
different block breaks to make sure that
it's all smoothed out
see I'm by doing this enough it should
generally be decently smooth it's
probably not going to end up being
perfect especially around this
transition here whether it isn't really
too much space or left I think I want to
actually transition this out a little
bit more as well yeah look like it's
actually going to be a bit of the
problem sometimes you find these these
little areas where you just can barely
get it smooth at all and you just want
to hit an extra bit of smoothing like
simple helixes like this usually work
out quite alright but it's especially
the transitions between different curves
which may end up being very hard to get
smooth now after I get a general idea of
what it should be like I like to just
hit smooth or button at once and that
should generally smooth it out to a
pretty alright level now testing the
right can give us a pretty good idea of
how smooth it is at the moment so let's
check that speed it seems like a pretty
nice drop down there yeah a little bit
too fast in here I'm going to erase that
up a bit
alright that seems pretty good now let's
get into a very steep drop and really go
down to the ground for the first real
drop of the ride and have to turn on the
banking offset again when we're starting
the new parts now you might also notice
that my banking offset is a little bit
exaggerated mostly I do this because
after smoothing it removes the banking
offset so I also want to make sure that
it's a little bit more than I need so
that ultra smoothing over and a more
accurate level and let's get down into a
sort of curved steep drop see how that
works
now for a lot of these elements here
also can have to remember that they
might look absolutely horrible kind of
like this those one ones you know you
haven't submitted it out yet but after
you're smoothing it you usually turn
into something that's decent so all
that's really important here is that we
get the general shape right and the fact
that it looks horrible at the moment in
terms of track work is something that we
don't really want to worry about quite
yet now over here I want to build what
is probably the signature elements of
coasters it's called an Immelmann turn
and a lot of these spinning coasters
have them so much so that they're kind
of a bit of a flagship thing for a motor
and what they are is they're a turn that
you make while you're also going over a
hill and the car banks to almost 90
degrees which means that depending on
what place in the car you're sitting
you're either looking directly at the
sky or directly at the ground now if it
wasn't entirely clear from that kind of
shaky explanation what these things look
like I'll kind of try to build one right
now you want to go up in a pretty steep
session something like this maybe a
little bit less steep now I'm going to
hit two high g-forces at the bottom
there and once your curving you kind of
want to make sure that layouts or like
the direction of the track kind of seems
into the same direction and what I mean
by that is that when you look from the
side it still looks like it's a straight
line even though we're clearly curving
toward the side here that's probably the
easiest way or like the rule of thumb to
remember how to make one of these things
so on the top over here as well we want
to bank it quite a bit just like that so
that when we get to the top you can't
really notice that it's a separate curve
just like that that actually looks quite
good and once we're on this other side
here we want to start banking back the
track there we go something like that
and going back to the ground again see
looks like it's a little bit too steep
like that oh and we are just a tiny bit
too low here so I'm going to move down
the entire elements which shouldn't be
too hard
when I finish off this side and if we
grab the entire element just like this
we should be able to lower it like that
there we go now let's smooth at the
beginning and in the last section with
the elements to make sure that the
transitions are still correct but it
should make this with a slightly better
speed than it just bit
now we go that's quite good looks like
this could be thanked a little bit more
maybe we want to bank it a tiny bit more
on the top as well and make sure that
these points have some smoothing as well
but that looks like a pretty all right
Immelman curve now these come in
slightly different shapes and sizes as
well but the very basic premise is that
you have that almost kind of half pipe
esque movement going through the top of
that hill and coming down again on the
other side here and I just love the way
that this element looks also keep in
mind and this is something that I
completely forgot so you're going to
have to unlock the cars and just
realized that's what we're going to need
this space for so we're going to unlock
the car spinning here because as you
might have noticed the cars weren't
actually spinning reason for that was
that the chorus pin wasn't actually
unlocked yet and as soon as you put an
unlocked car spin elements in there the
cars are going to spin and this is
basically the look that we're going to
want to have and you see on this element
as well all in this case it doesn't
actually work because it kind of
horizontal but you'll see that the car
sort of stops spinning and you kind of
crest up the hill and back again with a
car kind of staying in the same position
which is kind of interesting
so here we're going to go back up again
I feel like it's time for another one of
these block breaks trying to figure out
where exactly these book rates should be
headed I think it's good to make a curve
back into the location where we just
know where so that's going to start make
a big curve into that direction see what
kind of speed we have left one three
crescents top of that hill yeah that
looks like a pretty decent speed to do a
book break although maybe we are kind of
messing with these supports on the other
side so that's something that I do kind
of want to avoid
so let's kind of do it like this
hopefully that two types
I think that's doable let's check the
speed and before the car is here and
it's quickly smooth out that curve looks
not too bad although I think we can do
some more banking for it yeah with some
extra banking that's going to be a
pretty fine curve all right so it's time
for another one of these block breaks
and the rest of the layout is pretty
much very similar to these parts as well
just a lot of twisting curves and turns
and some slightly banked parts you could
also add a slightly smaller mm went
through but since this one is already
quite small and I think there's too much
of a point in that's some small airtime
hops and stuff like that can also work
so I'm just going to finish it off in a
very similar way from this point onward
looks like small helix coming very low
to the ground might be very interesting
after the element which we have over
here one thing to also remember about
these coasters is to try to make them as
compact as possible kind of stay very
close to the point of the track which
you've built earlier because these are
also supposed to be some slightly lower
budget rights some family rides which
you can fit in a very tight footprint so
that's something that I also want to
keep in mind here but that seems like a
pretty good helix again it looks
absolutely terrible but after some
smoothing it is kind of going into the
direction that I want to so it will be
fine alright now this could actually be
a bit of an airtime hop in here I just
realized it's not too often that you see
it but I think it is actually a pretty
interesting element so since we have a
straight section going on here think I
might as well try that and see how we
get out of it now I'm just smoothing
this all out as per usual and hopefully
in the end there should be a pretty
smooth element as well you'll notice
very often as well that as soon as you
do this quite a lot no matter how much
you hit the smooth button it doesn't
really move
as much anymore like you'll notice that
when I select all of the track pieces
and start hitting smooth at this point
it changes it a little bit but the more
you do it the less it changes and
there's kind of this moment where when
this has happened for a few track pieces
for a few times already I think that's
the best moment to just grab everything
at once and just smooth it all out in
one go and usually you have a very
smooth track section after that alright
now we're almost at the height of the
station and we already have three block
break sections so I think this is a good
time to get into the last helix and do a
bit of twisty track before we get back
into this session which isn't too big of
an issue at this point since we're also
going to have an extra block break
section just before the station which
means block for block break sections in
the end which is pretty good something
like three four five blocks I broke
block pretty sections there we go it's
something that I would definitely go for
with a question like this and as you can
see we are losing quite a bit of speed
here and one thing that we also want to
make sure is that it doesn't really
become too obvious that we're losing all
of the speed so as we're getting toward
the end of the coaster here I also want
to make the helixes a little bit tighter
so that they kind of feel just as fast
as the foster helixes which are a lot
less tight although I do try and kind of
get to the other side of the lift over
here let's see if we can actually still
make this tiny bit wider but yeah I'll
finish off the layout with some slightly
twisty track sections and see how that
works out now with this final helix I
want to be very careful since this is a
really small helix and smoothing out too
much roll just make the helix too small
and kind of get rid of the round shape
to it
so be very careful with this moving and
don't be afraid to just kind of move the
track back every now and then to get a
very circular shape that gets gradually
smaller as the coaster gets higher into
that curve into that hill and so on
down a bit since as you can see we are
really hitting some break section speed
in there in fact it is a little bit too
slow so realistically I should probably
lower this entire thing a little bit and
give it some extra speed to work with
now after one final round of smoothing
this part of the layout is pretty much
done and the entire layout is more or
less done it's a bit more helix heavy
than I kind of would have liked like
some s bends in these kinds of courses
are really fun as well so just some
parts where you just kind of go back and
forth between very short curves but I
think the helix is work out best in not
making this thing very compact and
getting as much as we can out of the
coaster since it's really slow down
until almost a complete stop at the end
of the layout so that's quite good so
here I just want to add some friction
brakes to slow it down to an even more
manageable speed as we get into the
catwalks and finally add some final
break some final block breaks to make
sure that we can actually add some extra
train to this in fact I feel like we can
yeah we have space to add some extra
block brakes to this as well so might as
well I'm just going to put two block
brakes here near the end mmm maybe some
extra extra regular brakes and then into
the block brakes we go and you can see
we do have that slight incline over here
and if everything is good by the time
that we curve around to the station
maybe we need to go down a little bit
more we should be pretty much at the
exact same level as the station is and
yup we are so with a bit more smoothing
this curve too should be the way it is
supposed to be there we go and we have a
need curve back into the station in fact
the brake run is so long at this point
that I feel we can actually remove a
small part of this and actually make the
brakes get longer from this section and
just have a regular connection for the
track here
all right now our cursor is looking
pretty swell but there's one more thing
to note when you want to turn on the
blog section so that we can run multiple
trains realistically so let's get the
number of cars up to about four as a
first test and kind of see how that goes
I would sort of love to go for five but
the important thing here is that I want
to try to make sure that the cars can
continually keep running the tracks
without having to wait at the block
sections so by the time that this car
gets to the next block section it will
hopefully already have passed that with
a car being in front of it which means
that the cars don't have to wait on any
of the book sections which is usually
why I would recommend getting one less
car then you can in total and at least
test the amount of cars before you
actually go through with it so it looks
like we might actually be able to run
five that's that's that real quick all
right there we go it's actually working
with five so we scrap that it actually
works the main reason that this works I
miss is something important to keep in
mind is that the distance between the
block sections is very similar it
doesn't have to be exactly equal but by
the time that this car reaches this book
section the car in front of it will
already have cleared the book section in
front of it and that's basically why we
can see that the car can pass over all
of the block section breaks without
having to wait on a single one of them
and that is what we're looking for so
yeah I'm pretty happy with this layout
as it stands right now and that's
basically it for this tutorial
couple of notes are really in the end
that you want to keep those book
sections in mind if you want to
realistically do this make sure that the
spaces between the book sections are
large enough and you've got enough block
sections to actually run quite a few
trains on these coasters you could have
some more twisty sections and some less
helixes but these are some of the basic
elements and layouts looks that these
coasters have and as for doing other
things with these coasters there are
actually some very interesting stuff
that you can do with these things
although spending coasters actually make
for some pretty great indoor coasters
like for example crushers coaster at
Disneyland Paris or left track and
Hershey Park which are both also the
standard SE mm model except with some
very minor differences but since these
kinds of coasters are already very
compact anyway you don't really need to
design a layout specifically for the
indoor aspect and you can usually just
kind of build around it and add scenery
around the ride to make it an indoor
coaster especially in this case I think
since all you really have to cover up is
a big sort of triangle pyramid shaped
trapeze oh there we go thing around the
main layout that we have going on here
with just one pipe turning out for this
station you don't actually even need
that large of a building to even turn
this layout into a indoor coaster even
if the layout isn't built for it and it
could be a little bit more compact these
are some great coaches if you want to
build an indoor coaster but you don't
have too much space to do it with now
that will be all for this tutorial on
spinning coasters I hope you learned
something from it and if you're still
interested in these courses in general I
definitely recommend checking out some
of the links below especially the roller
coaster tycoon Psilakis the roller
coaster tycoon database which has all
kinds of different coasters basically
also ordered based on the type of
spinning coasters that they are so
there's lots of inspirational material
in there and for some reason and this is
in the way any advertising or anything
there are actually some pretty detailed
brochures on these kinds of courses as
well but anyway you're probably just
looking to build a pretty cool neat
little spinning coaster and hopefully
this will help you on your way in that
mission as well so yeah thank you guys
for watching and I hope to see you guys
next time